[Music]
and to be double nominated for these
awards means a lot to me you know i've
been a fan of independent film for years
there's something special about making
projects in this way where you have to
figure out every piece of it and i think
any show that is honoring that process
is the place to be and you can tell when
you're here like people are hanging out
and like it's a celebration
to be a writer director like having kids
in the 1800s you have to have a lot of
them because most of them aren't going
to make it to adulthood
receiving this recognition and
nominations it's such a blessing i feel
like all the dust on my back is
beginning to evaporate and i finally
don't have a chip on my shoulder and
really i see hollywood finally beginning
to open their hearts and open their
minds to us in the deaf community
my dad was a jockey and i grew up in the
world of horse racing and i just felt
like the people who worked in these
working class tracks had not been really
seen
this is my star udokir yes
who is this man
introducing i'm sorry
you know i'm excited to see peter
sarsgaard who i did orphan with when i
was a kid and i haven't seen him since i
was 12. i can't remember me i seduced
you when i was 10 years old oh wow this
got kicked in a movie in a movie
they're going to cut that right out it's
right it's going to make it in the cut i
know it
the idea that people are actually
recognizing you know our work
collectively is just it's just wonderful
i don't think i've ever won anything
here before have you i've sat in the
audience i've seen the audience i've
seen the audience a lot so it feels
really streaming
it feels really good to come here
already had won something we already
have an award for the best best ensemble
so that's the only way to do it the only
way i'm doing it from now on i'm only
going to things where i know i've won a
few years ago where i lost
to an unknown actress named glenn close
but we're happy for her
it could be the beginning it could be
the beginning of something great for her
this film is a exploration of the
so-called chinese dream and even though
it's about china i hope for it to
resonate with an american and a western
audience
is all the details wrong he said
congratulations on your film it was a tv
show
good luck it's a movie if you don't find
a mouthpiece as an artistic person
that can really crush you and
independent cinema really allows people
to find their voices you have to make a
really good independent movie to come to
this festival
we've been through
biblical levels of obstacles old
testament not new
i feel like a million bucks right now
growing up you don't see a lot of native
people on tv now kids don't have to
worry about that anymore they get to
look on tv and see us and like see
themselves we're creating the shows that
we wanted to see growing up grateful
that we're all here representing our
people very few of us get to walk these
carpets
you